about schedule sighs thank you good
afternoon my name is IDO I'm gonna tell
you about merch about summaries today my
co-presenter is not here is Jason Justin
Taylor and this is shared work with a
few of our colleagues V Rhodes Kevin
Lang John forget the last names I
apologize let me I'll get two of them
Alex and John I'd be okay me for
forgetting the last names this is the
this is this work came out of practical
needs about summarizing and working with
large data and end up being a very
interesting fertile ground for actual
research so I'll breathe through really
streaming and the the need for multiple
summaries in big data and then we'll
kind of dive in to kind of just see some
of the theoretical results and some of
the practical applications so this is a
emerge of those two things so in in
stand out in stand out data mining or
kind of the old-school
thoughts of how we do data analysis we
just collect data on some disk and then
we compute and load load and memory and
compute on it and then we started
thinking about data as being too large
and we collect it on a bunch of disks
and we you know we then still have to
compute it in memory then we think about
things like MapReduce or you know other
scatter Gothel approaches where we load
the data on a bunch of machines and we
kind of send the executables or the code
to the data and you know we have some
form of interaction you can think about
search as being or databases being kind
of like that as well where the data is
more static and the execution goes and
is or the communication
if you know I don't wanna I don't need
to sell you on the idea of the explosion
of data and so this is like a meta
infographic on big data so this is an
explosion of infographics about big data
and so we have is already
we can't even stored infographics about
big data anymore and as the is the head
of Amazon AI labs we work with a lot of
amazon about the amazon cloud services
like sage maker which is the new machine
learning platform Kinesis or streaming
solution quick site is a bi in analytics
platform and so on all of those deal
with terabytes and petabytes of data and
they need to do the be very interactive
in the same time very efficient and
quick and so we have to work in in a
much more efficient way the streaming
model is an incredibly efficient method
by which you funded all your data into
something that does some creates a
summary of your data which creates
something that we call a sketch from
this point on and that sketch gives you
a good approximation to whatever it is
that you are trying to compute whether
it's some statistic or some property of
the data and with merchantville
summaries which is kind of the focus of
this entire talk is is an even more
restricted setting well the data is not
even collected in one machine actually
you have a lot of machines collecting
separate parts of the data so the data
is shouted in some way that is unknown
to you and how completely arbitrary each
machine computes a small summary and
only those summaries are shared with
some global sketch that just merges
those different data structures it needs
to be accurate and faithfully represent
the data like the global the global data
right so there is no assumption on
stochasticity there is no assumption on
how the data is charted the data is
shortened in some completely arbitrary
way and you can think about those as
maybe machines collecting some user
actions from all over the world and you
can't assume that the you know your
users in Europe behave the same as your
users in
South America okay but I still want to
have some global behavior so mm why the
why is is so important so if you think
about big data and computing things like
number of unique users who visit all my
web sites all over the world okay think
about amazon.com maybe really caring
about something like that okay the way
you would think to do this is I'll take
my data I will I will shuffle it to
other machines to do a joint so I will
kind of share them by key or by user ID
somehow these machines would unify the
keys will count how many unique keys
they see they just have the sum and then
sense and the sum to some central
machine but this thing here is a shuffle
this is you're actually broadcasting all
the data from one set of machines to the
other okay so this might move anywhere
from gigabytes or terabytes of data and
that could take hours and be cost you
hundreds of dollars if you do this with
sketches each machine would only sketch
its local data it sends only the sketch
which could be kilobytes and this thing
is going to be merged in a matter of
milliseconds and this entire thing will
be done okay
and so we've so this thing actually
takes go on so sketches your is a I'll
go into what how we actually sketch what
does that to okay think about this some
compact or something that takes create
some very concise summary of the data
and depending on what it is that you
want to summarize you know it it does
something else
okay so I'll talk I'll go I'll give you
a very long list of what those things
could be gone
yeah that one this one what's sort of
the temporal relationship but I some
queries are sketch result sir continuous
right so I yeah for the for all of this
talk I'm gonna I'm gonna assume data
just keeps on coming all the time so
think about those visit those two
websites or some machines in some
factory spewing out some sensor
measurements or whatever there's going
to be some ongoing stream of data that
might be collected by I don't know
hundreds of thousands of different
sensors so machines yeah so this thing
yeah you might we might actually push
this thing to some front end thing and
you might want to refresh this over a
few seconds or whatever or ever you
whatever Ivan whenever somebody actually
wants to look at it or something yeah
so well do well does this idea also come
up if we look at just data mining or
taking statistics or doing all sorts of
analysis if you wanna have if you have
this data coming over some period of
time the standard things into windowing
so I take three four five ten days circa
that may they be goes far enough to in
the past I will do some I'll cribs some
process whereby I'll take those like
safely days I do some you know crunching
and I'll create some model or some
measurement that I care about but in
this way I actually have to process
every piece of data three times and my
models only contain three days worth of
data whereas if I can do this collection
and merging I can actually sketch things
only once and then just merge with the
day prior so each data is where data is
processed only once and my models or my
statistics are actually valid for all of
history so it's a double wind the same
thing is true for dynamic windowing of
queries along these lines if I have some
binary merging tree then if I want to
know some statistic about some sequence
into the past I can now just take these
three nodes of the tree and just merge
those sketches and I would get exactly
the range that I care about and I don't
have to go and do the merges for
everything and if you know what OLAP is
is kind of forget the online analysis I
forget something I forget the name there
the P but it's a common thing so you'd
have a set of events and you might want
to care about some select operation so
you want to know you know this is a map
of Westeros so you might care about how
many you know I have some events that I
want to know the latency of you want to
say maybe I want to know the latency of
events in all of Westeros or maybe I
want to know and just I think it's the
north in like the first quartile so I
might have a sketch or one of those data
structure for each
it'll be for each month and to get the
quote that I just merged three of those
and to get the entire region I just
merge the category and that's that's a
very common use case so I just save a
small amount of data and I still get a
lot of query a lot of query combinations
that are possible so I'm now going to go
into the hardness results of what's
possible what's impossible but a lot of
things are impossible in this model it's
very easy to show that for example if
you want to compute the exact median of
a bunch of numbers it's impossible and
I'm not going to go into why but you can
convince yourself that that's impossible
but if you're willing to get even a
small amount of approximation and in
most of those cases you don't mind
getting a tiny amount of error or
approximation then we actually have very
good algorithms to a lot of different
things from counting distinct elements
and estimating entropy of streams and of
course all sorts of samplings for
matrices you can do low low income
oxidation specification for vectors you
can do clustering in linear regression
and all sorts of machine learning and
density estimations
we have some results for graphs this is
kind of semi streaming so the space is
proportional the number of nodes usually
in the graph and not the number of edges
which is polynomial so it's called semi
streaming usually but still so in this
talk I'm going to tell you about an open
source library that we've been writing
for several years and these are my
colleagues I'm just gonna do them
justice now so it's Lee Road the chief
architect of this thing Kevin Lang who's
been the lead scientist on this project
for a long time and it's rock walking
for me several years Alec psittacosis
lead engineer on this project also for a
long time Justin Taylor is my
co-presenter was not here professors in
Georgetown this is myself
John and John Malkin also a scientist
and engineer working on this project for
several years this we've just hit the
500 stars on github I don't know if you
know what that means but for those of
you who do I you know we enjoyed that
okay this library that I'm going to show
you is actually used in Yahoo and splice
and Joey and Amazon in in many other
companies its production ready and not
only the production ready it actually
contains a lot of the very new research
that we have on this topic some of those
you know the latest publication is still
in submission we have papers in Fox in
in in internet measurement conferences
in napes and other places so this is a
you know so this is a one of those rare
occasions where cutting-edge technology
and code actually meets cutting-edge
science so in this talk I'm going to
just cover quickly counting distinct
elements item frequencies and
approximate quantiles all of those
problems have been studied carefully and
by many others before us when we
approach these problems we really care
about writing great algorithms that work
in production so it's somewhat
simplicity of the code correctness of
movable correctness because those are
going to be used in the wild where we
don't know where they're used and in the
same time actual efficiency so we don't
you know for us we truly very much care
about the constants okay so you know
it's all you know Big O notation is is
it's not exactly where it's at often as
you will know how much time do I have I
don't have a I have plenty of time
excellent
all right so counting distinct elements
this goes back to you know the seminal
paper by Alan matheus in Sega D and
there's been a long list of authors on
of papers on this topic including some
people in this crowd the work by Kevin
Lee and Justin took a set of these
results and unified them into this
general framework by which you take
items you hash them to
value between zero and one and you keep
everything that falls beneath some value
theta okay and from the values from if
you do this carefully from the value of
theta and the number of elements you
have the map to the value lower than
theta you can get the statistics that
you care about and they show that a very
large number of several algorithms
actually map just to different different
mechanisms by which you decrease theta
with time of course if theta is 1/2 all
the time you'll end up something a lot
of things and you'll run out of memory
so you have to make state a smaller with
time they give new variants bounds and
of course there's a very careful
implementation of these algorithms and
what they you know what we see is that
if we do this carefully then we take
things like adaptive sampling and kmv
which are both instances of this theta
family of theta algorithms and if you
compare them to an algorithm they called
alpha algorithm I'm not sure why but
then practically just outperforms both
in update time and in evaluation time
pretty consistently so there is there
isn't this like jagged behavior of
adaptive sampling and it just
consistently outperform scan V okay I'm
not going to go into you know so here I
want to show you actually want to switch
to a live demo for a second I know this
is a theory crowd so this is not common
but I'll do it anyway if you want you
can if you have a Mac you can just brew
install sketches it's that's those two
lines you might have to install homebrew
before that which is kind of the the
package manager for Macs
but let me let me show you something for
a second
I want to see my screen okay you see
that all right so
alright ok so I have this file that just
contains numbers the number in place I
is a uniform number it's like uniform
integer between 0 and I you can convince
yourself that the expectation of you
number of uniques is n over 2 if you do
that it's a nice exercise so if you want
it if I if you just give you this file
of numbers and I tell you with
duplicates I want to just tell me how
many unique numbers that are here so the
standard way to do this in in in Python
who does a sir in UNIX who's a UNIX
pipes guy so how do you uniquely fire
things in what you can do unique but
then you have to sort first if you just
do unique that's just gonna so you have
to sort so if you do this unique and
then and then just count the lines okay
so this would hang I would just put what
oh yeah of course this will not work so
you're right I can just ask sort to
unique if I to begin with that's not
gonna work I mean that's gonna take
forever to but it turns out that sort
spends most of its time string comparing
between the so these are strings it
doesn't know it's numbers cuz it's a
file
they just think so comparing lines so I
can tell sort these are actually numbers
okay
and that thing will work it will take
some time but it'll work
what and just tells it to parse the
lines as numbers okay that's a good
question so this is five million things
if I just do this it's it's ten million
and you can see but also that IO is not
the point so I just typed it into God
you know so it's it was pretty quick so
you saw how long sword took you know and
it actually had to load the entire thing
in the memory that's roughly seventy
four megabytes and that's what's
happening so if you try to do this with
data sketches it would look like that
oops oh we just I apologize and just
changed we just change the
Oh Sato sorry
all right so that's it and it tells you
it's approximate it is 49
sorry 4.9 million and it's between four
point and four point and then four point
eight and five point one and you can
change the accuracy and so on
but the interesting thing is that this
thing not only did it finish in like a
tenth of the time and actually only use
like a few kilobytes of memory instead
of 74 megabytes if you do it once on a
laptop that's nice but it's not a huge
difference if you try to do a hunt like
a hundred million of those on a server
you know it this would be possible and
something else will just explode or just
will never finish so what so it's 1 over
square root the size of the sketch
roughly so I can change the size of the
sketch I can set K to be larger yeah so
now this is way more accurate so this is
saving like 200 2000 K 20 K 200 K items
okay instead of yeah so you can decide
how much memory you're gonna use the
more memory used the more accurate the
sketches yeah time pounds are they like
a confidence interval good I forget I
think it's 95 I have to get back to you
on that one I don't remember
I think it's 95
okay so this was just my that was just a
live example of why we care about these
things so this was a so another problem
I'm gonna introduce his item frequencies
so again a long list of authors starting
from I think the the most significant
paper on this is not here
aha it is alright one of your many
people in this room is colleague mr.
fresh agrees a paper from the 80s on how
to approximate frequencies or number of
counts of items in a stream when we
started with this problem we notice that
most of our customers are asking
actually asking for weighted updates so
they would say ok we it's not we we
don't add one to count URLs of items we
actually have weights so think about
this is like number of you know cycles
spent on some process or time spent by
some user on some application or so on
so the problem is defined by I have
updates of item IDs with some weight and
I want to be able to approximate the
weight of the of every item up to some
epsilon arrow and it's epsilon times the
total weight of the entire stream okay
and when we took on this problem we
managed to actually improve both the the
worst case update time improve the
merging procedure so now merging is
significantly faster and more actually
also simpler we improved the estimator
so there are two algorithms so Mishra
agrees of also called frequent items has
one type of estimator and another paper
called another algorithm called
space-saving has a different kind of
estimate and we actually showed that if
you a hybrid between them tends to be
more accurate it's a practical implement
this is a practical observation both of
them provably are somehow the same and
of course with a very careful
implementation of the algorithm itself
so let me just tell you about about the
idea there and the idea is very simple
and it's very similar to the both
frequent items and space-saving it's
just if you don't know what I think it's
it's a cute algorithm it's it's worth
seeing I just keep a bunch of counts of
items sorry and and the total weight
when I have when I get a new item with
that I need to agree eight the weight
for I just add it to the you know to the
sum and then I get maybe a new item that
I don't have a count of for I create a
counter for it with appropriate weight
but then I ran out of space so what I do
is I take roughly the the median weight
that I have in my data structure and I
just you know I just chop everything by
that amount okay which of course if you
take out the median then roughly half
the items are gone and you have space to
insert more things okay and the the
interesting thing is you know that
finding the median can be done finding
an approximate median can be done very
efficiently so I don't even need to this
to be like an exact media you just have
an approximate me and the value and just
chop everything by that amount so if you
just sample or take any way of
approximating the median we see that the
error is actually not much worse than
what happens if you take the smallest
item or if you try to do the most
careful thing possible and in fact you
can make the arrows be completely the
same if you just make this sketch
slightly bigger
okay but the update times are
significantly faster so these are the
update times of other algorithms and
this is the update time of of this
algorithm that I just show you
there's no painting going on no there's
no painting it's an excited you exact
match on the ID and then an account so
that yeah you can think about
so we've so for this problem we actually
investigated so I'm showing you just
kind of the bottom line all the all the
results on count sketches and how mean
sketches and also bucketing and hashing
tricks and so on just end up being
significantly less accurate and yeah I
mean I can it's it's so much to discuss
but there's been you know we've took us
a long time to evaluate that this is
actually in our opinion the winning
strategy okay the surprising thing is
just as a curiosity I'll tell you in a
second how this is used but just as a
curiosity the interesting thing to the
one of the hardest things to do here was
to figure out so here you have a hash
table with like L objects in it and you
need to delete half the items in it so
if you've worked on data structures you
might think yourself Oh deleting things
from a hash table is o of one who cares
but it's the Big O thing so if try to
think of us try to think of a hash table
that optimizes the operation of deleting
as an arbitrary subset of half the keys
and you'll see it's not an easy problem
I specifically optimize that for almost
a month and I had to go back to like
literature from the 70s so just an
example on how this is used if you look
at oh let me forget that I'm not in
oh good so if you look at mail that
yahoo mail gets and this is a no these
are all slides from some work you can
try to you can try to see that some so
getting an email from so if you get an
email from Payless saying you've some
old you have some other confirmation
getting another email from dang saying
that you have an older ship now you know
maybe you can think about this is any
shopping or any like any other
interaction that you have with the world
through emails or with some servers you
can figure out that the probability that
you get this email given that you've
gotten this one before is significantly
higher than just getting this one in it
like independently so to do this you
have to figure out you have to look at
every pair of types of emails and figure
out what's the relative lift in
probability and that's a squared problem
that's impossible
but if you use these sketches you can
just add the the like one of the
probability one over the ground
probability for each element for each
email to seeing the subsequent element
this problem goes down from being of n
square tubing of in this goes from being
impossible to being possible so this is
you know so you can think of sketches
takings of n2 of one which is taking
something hard to being something easy
but in systems oftentimes you have many
of those so it takes something like of n
square two o of n which makes something
impossible to something hard and by the
way if you do this you start seeing a
lot of interesting patterns so of course
all the confirmations move to shipping
and things like reminders to pay bills
end up with people canceling stuff
okay streaming quantiles I'm almost out
of time but in streaming quantize we
have two papers on this so this was a
so let me define the problem first you
get a bunch of items just think about
them as numbers for now but they can be
anything that's compatible anything
that's like full ordering on things and
a rank of an item is just a number of
items in the stream which are smaller
than it so this would be like point six
times n is the rank of this color okay
and you need to process a stream and be
able to produce an overkill that can
compute our prime which computes all the
ranks for every possible thing up to sub
epsilon in yellow so it's approximating
the quantile of the rank of every
possible thing again a long list of work
that we did not invent this problem you
can uniformly sample things and then
there's a sequence of results and so
maybe surprisingly this result was
actually before chronologically before
this one but third billion Ostrovsky had
a result I'm sure I mean uniform sample
gets gets here solution wonderful
epsilon square you want to do better
than that you can get one over epsilon
look whatever sin of epsilon which was
thought to be optimal by most of the
people that I talked to it was not
manageable and it was by no means a
simple algorithm and there is a paper
that introduces it actually introduces a
merge above summaries by Agra Valcour
mode Wang Philip when Yi that gives a
log to the three halves one over epsilon
over epsilon solution which we
implemented in the library but that
didn't seem correct to me I don't know
log should three halves didn't seem like
the right thing I mean I didn't I felt
like this must something must be off and
so Zohar Cornyn Kevin Lang and myself
worked on it and we we figured that you
can actually get a square log 1 over
epsilon over epsilon solution but that
is both simple and mirja ball
and in fact you can get a oh I apologize
this is not an X so you can get the log
squirrel of one of our epsilon and get
merged well so this should be a V this
is a mistake okay and you can get a log
log 1 over epsilon over epsom solution
but that's neither simple nor merciful
and we proved that this is optimal space
wise okay so so you can get space
optimality but lose millage ability or
you can have merge ability and have
something slightly less than space
optimal if you want to try to get both
this is still open this is a great
research problem and
I have a couple of minutes I'm gonna
show you roughly how this works I think
it's interesting maybe show you some
results and I'll conclude with that so
mmm so let's define this buffers how
these like quantiles things work I'll
have a buffer this buffer is size K so
I'm going to store K items in my buffer
from the stream once the buffer is full
I'm going to halt for a second I'm going
to sort these things and then I'm going
to delete half the items either the odds
or the events and then the items that I
didn't delete out put in double the
weight okay so what does that look like
think about this is like some kind of
adaptive sampling right if I if I choose
to keep the even ones then you know if
for this value so think about this is
now the not the stream this is the
x-axis okay see this now this is the
this is the number of sorted so if I ask
how many items are smaller than this
query then it's two every time so this
is item is weight too so I actually
didn't change the rank at all so this
thing didn't suffer any approximation
any error but if my rank was odd then I
thought I merged the 7 to the 5 or the 5
to the 7 in which case the rank has
changed by one so every time I do this
merge I only suffer an arrow of 1 even
though I've deleted half the items ok so
so if you you know if you process the
entire stream this way I mean you've
taken K items every time so the like the
streams of length n so and you've done
this n over K times
so the error they introduced between
this stream is and that stream is at
most n over K you still have a stream of
half the size so you still have to do
something with it but that's easy you
just pipe it into one of another gadget
like that okay and just keep piping it
to more and more gadgets until the
stream is short enough to fit into one
of them so you get so you just need log
login of those but
buffers to fit the entire stream into it
and the error just multiplies so we had
n over K now we have n log n over K and
if you set K to be log n over epsilon
then you get what you wanted then the
total space complexity is log square n
over epsilon this is an a sketch called
mrl this is again from the 80s or maybe
90s I think 80s there is a famous paper
by Greenwald in Kahana that shows how to
do this terminus to clean login of Arab
saw so they removed one log n term but
I'm not going to explain how that works
it's a bit of a complicated algorithm
but what Agarwal commode Wang Philippe
where need showed is that you can
replace some of the buffers with sample
sampling and you can do the you can
instead of deleting either the odds or
the even you can do this randomly
and sorry you get oops you get this
result that I showed you that I told you
about a log to the three halves and what
we showed later is that in fact you can
make the the first buffers smaller and
somehow not hurt the performance or the
gate or the approximation at all and
that removes one of the log n factors so
you have sampling and then buffers have
become bigger bigger and bigger until
this the size K and the interesting
thing is this this sampling and these
buffers kind of look alike so you can
think about this is this adaptive
sampling instead of switching between
sampling and and sketching it kind of
slowly start moves from sampling to
something looks a little bit more like
sketching a little bit more like
sketching and so on and then you can
replace the top buffers with this gk
sketch and get the optimal thing but I
really flew through this thing but I I
think it's put in I hope you got at
least something out of it
but the interesting
is that if you if you take this sketch
that I showed you and tuned the case
such that it aligns with what you'd
expect from the previous best result so
this is the air I mean it's different
case but they kind of match on the air
the size of the the size of the sketches
that you get are significantly smaller
so this is these are significantly more
compact in in practice and in fact we
have a follow-up paper that gives a
bunch of new set of tricks that improve
the constants even further and so this
is so the the better algorithm that I
showed you a second ago is is the orange
one and we you know we managed to
actually improve it even more so in this
paper in this talk I only showed you
three things that the top three ones we
have solutions for some of the others
some of the others some of the things on
this list are not implemented many other
problems are open and especially things
with regression with machine learning
anything that has to do with densities
and of course things that are touch on
the deep learning and gradient descent
and all sorts of stuff like that
are wide open so there is you know
pretty much any streaming algorithm that
you think about try to think about in
the meltable
setting try to think about how I can see
my data in different machines and take
only the sketches and merge them and if
you can do this in a provable way let us
know and would love to really figure out
how to actually get it into this library
[Applause]
the next main organ problem
so yeah it's interesting so surprisingly
yeah so clustering is is something we're
working on it's still open but
potentially doable
I think problems in in machine learning
and proper machine learning are going to
be very very hard
again those are things we want to work
on but I've they are you know maybe it's
it's you know things that you guys can
invest in I mean we we just don't have
the bandwidth to get to them yet but
things even even simple things like
logistic regression oh not to talk about
deep learning all sorts of stuff like
that this is like beyond the horizon
yeah I mean interesting
it's terrifying this most in demand yeah
so I unique counts is actually like just
counting unique items is very much is
very needed and just because the
alternative is so painful and awful like
you really have this like huge joins and
huge database operations to do something
that if you are willing to get like a
0.1% error it will be done in an instant
right and the vast majority of people
don't care about that let me know they
you know for dashboarding especially
they create some chart you know and they
just look at it you know I mean if there
was a 1% there you wouldn't even I mean
the width of the line is so heavy he
tells does so it's so it's it's a time
spent either by users or by machines
anything that has do with budgeting like
cycles or you know some people and the
yeah so so yeah so we're in factories
and in IOT systems and so on and you
know you want to have that you know you
you have a you have a compute center and
you want to know
give me the distribution of cycles pail
process name of process
how many processors there and you know
you definitely don't want to have all of
them save logs and funnel data in and
out and do aggregations that alone would
kill you right especially if you want to
have some ongoing thing if you want to
see there's some process starts going
renegade and start like growing you know
this is super heavy if you want to do
this so this any interesting thing by
the way to note is that a ton of the
literature in streaming algorithms is
dedicated to turnstile and insertion
deletion and so on some is dedicated to
manageability but not nearly as much we
see in practice that people don't
necessarily care about deleting stuff
they much more care about things being
eligible than about being able to add in
delete items and those tend to conflict
by the way algorithmically I mean if you
if one works then now if you have a
linear sketch anything works but linear
sketches tend to not be optimal for
hey captain the speaker yes